noisette t noisetiers ajouté par la
suite
oui enfin lâché cela va faire trois
semaines que thierno 16 ans est arrivé
dans le esse esse de joué-lès-tours
après un périple de plusieurs mois
depuis la guinée conakry à travers le
désert et la méditerranée
l'adolescent s'exerce au déchiffrage il
était avec moi non compact elle même
n'est pas du tout la paix tout le temps
avec les feuilles de salade et allez je
vais quitter l'enfance
cliquez ici dans ce centre et reçoit une
aide dans ses démarches administratives
sa recherche de formation et de logement
comme lui 116 jeunes ont demandé de
l'aide au service de la protection de
l'enfance au premier trimestre 2010 7 50
d'entre eux ont été admis comme mineur
isolé une influence anormal qu'ils
saturent cette structure est ralenti son
bon fonctionnement
les temps d'attentes sont plus longs
pendant l'évaluation ce qui fait quoi là
on prend par la suite du retard sur
l'accompagnement
on a on a quand même pas mal de jeunes
qui arrivent à l'âge de 17 ans et pour
tous ces jeunes là effectivement plus
plus en plus en retard plus l'urgence
est grande et plus c'est compliqué de de
pouvoir travailler une insertion correct
pour eux que ce soit ce soit sociale
économique dans les temps avant leur
majorité pour les départements qui
financent 500000 euros par mois à
l'accueil des mineurs non-accompagnés la
situation est critique son quota légal
de 130 et une place d'accueil est
régulièrement dépassé les enfants
surnuméraires sont dispatchés dans
d'autres services aussi sous tension
avec des charges des rsa qui augmente le
5 millions d'euros l'année dernière plus
bas ce qui est normal à l'accueil de ces
jeunes étrangers
on varie d'un moment donné on aura plus
de solutions soit l'état donc conforte
nos finances c'est à dire paye ce
pourquoi ils nous donnent des charges
soit ya l'augmentation de l'impôt et en
l'occurrence on ne veut pas aller à
l'augmentation des impôts le conseil
départemental veut peser sur l'état pour
obtenir des moyens supplémentaires car
les craint de ne pas pouvoir faire face
à de nouvelles vagues d'immigration qui
viennent en général avec les beaux jours
ces adolescents viennent principalement
de l'afrique de l'ouest l'afrique
centrale ou bien du bangladesh et
d'afghanistan
un tiers d'entre migrent pour des
raisons politiques les autres pour fuir
la misère
parmi eux des jeunes filles rescapées
des réseaux de prostitution et d'
esclavage moderne